you could call it the great divide when
it comes to the future of work ipsos
polling done exclusively for global news
suggests people who have worked remotely
during the pandemic are split on the
return to the office but united in
embracing flexible schedules many
canadians want the changes that the
pandemic brought to the workplace to be
permanent and for things to not go back
the way they were
before that fateful day in march 2020
when everything shut down in fact one in
three say they'd look for another job if
their employer forced them to work
exclusively at the office and yet 42
percent say they're happiest at their
place of work rather than working from
home the divide is pronounced among
younger workers nearly half of people
between the ages of 18 and 34 prefer to
be in the office rather than work
remotely now that may reflect a desire
to learn and connect with colleagues
from those starting out in their careers
but a little more than half of young
workers say they want to work from home
working remotely or in the workplace is
very much linked to the housing crisis
that we're seeing right now young people
are are struggling to save up for down
payments the average savings for remote
workers in 2021 was about two hundred
dollars a week or more than eleven
hundred dollars a year according to
cisco canada that's money saved on
commuting lunches out child care pet
care and wardrobe with a rapidly rising
cost of everything those numbers are
only going up attitudes on where and how
to work have shifted with 44 percent
saying their workplace now offers
flexible arrangements that didn't exist
pre-pandemic hybrid schedules are most
common in ontario where more than half
say their workplace has adopted a
flexible model followed by atlantic
canada and bc at 43 percent and quebec
38
this is one lasting change lasting
impact of the pandemic many appreciate
the new flexible working environment
want to stay that way and are willing to
change jobs to find it anne gaviola
global news toronto